presidente turco recep tayip erdogán ha
hablado esta misma tarde con su homólogo
ruso vladimir putin para intentar para
el conflicto de ucrania y mediar entre
la rusia de vladimir putin y la ucrania
de volodymyr al selenski así lo ha
explicado un comunicado oficial emitido
por la presencia de turquía que ha
explicado que turquía es intentando
presionar a rusia para que acepte imple
implante un alto al fuego que de momento
no se está cumpliendo en ucrania para
que después de este alto el fuego puedan
tomarse más seriamente las negociaciones
de paz entre rusia y ucrania sin embargo
a poco se será más de esta conversación
que según el comunicado de la presencia
de turquía durado casi o cerca de una
hora de conversación entre los dos
líderes los cuales se consideran y han
dicho en múltiples ocasiones en las que
se han encontrado que se consideran
amigos ahora mismo turquía se encuentra
en una posición muy delicada respecto a
este conflicto esta invasión rusa por
toda ucrania por varios motivos porque
rusia es el gran aliado de turquía
después de una europea en materia
comercial y económica y turquía no
podría permitirse perder a un socio
comercial en un momento de crisis
económica en turquía muy grave sin
embargo turquía también se muestra
favorable a ucrania y estatal ahora está
catalogando esta guerra de invasión rusa
y esta ayuda ucrania mandándole drones y
ayuda humanitaria turquía está ahora
mismo entre medias entre los dos bloques
los buques
de occidente y rusia y no quiere tomar
parte y por lo tanto se encuentra dice
ella misma como el único país que no ha
roto puentes con rusia y que el que
puede mediar entre tanto occidente como
moscú